good morning John in 1911 in a very
early science fiction novel Hugo
Gernsback became the first person to
predict personalized news when he wrote
the morning newspapers were transmitted
to the sleeping subscribers by wire at
about 5:00 a.m. the newspaper office
notified by each subscriber what kind of
news is desirable furnished only such
news more than a hundred years later
that future is more than now our
personalized news sources would more
accurately be called information and
entertainment feeds and they contain
everything from pictures of your
cousin's baby to the unfiltered thoughts
of the President of the United States
but in Gernsback future it was you who
decided what news you wanted to see and
that idea on its own may be troubling
but now who decides what ends up in your
feed isn't you it isn't even a person
it's a computer program and increasingly
a program that built itself in ways that
no one fully understands to satisfy not
your needs but the needs of the platform
these machines are given desired
outcomes but how they get there is up to
them and their goals are tightly held
industry secrets but here are two things
that are very clear one the information
in your feed and how it is served to you
can have a lasting effect on who you are
and how you feel and to the business
model of social media relies on selling
that power for a profit due to a failing
in facebook policy and enforcement
Cambridge analytical was able to create
psychological profiles of tens of
millions of Facebook users we have
somewhere close to four or five thousand
data points on every adult in the United
States and then they could create not
just advertisements but news stories and
even entire news outlets specifically to
amplify and exploit the fears and
anxieties of voters this was a violation
of Facebook's rules but not of any laws
because in the u.s. there are so few
laws regulating these companies in fact
Facebook doesn't want anyone else to
have your data because your data is
their most valuable asset
but as artificial intelligence gets
better even small amounts of data will
likely be enough smaller and smaller
signals are becoming clearer and clearer
machines are now able to tell with 91%
accuracy what a man's sexual orientation
is from profile photos if you're
wondering why Facebook is worth half a
trillion dollars it's because of its
ability to capture your attention and
because of what it knows about you when
fed enough data machines can determine
shocking detail with tiny amounts of
input and they will use what they know
about you your worldview and even your
emotional state to help others
manipulate you as long as those people
have the money to spend this is not a
secret conspiracy it's their business
model Facebook isn't the product that's
being sold Facebook is free you are not
the customer you are the product on the
social internet your attention is their
dollars and for them that means that
anything that gains attention is good
and whether they decide to have any
regard for truth for the stability of
society for the health of their users is
at the moment entirely up to them and
while some of us will dive into these
issues to at least understand most
people won't have the time to do that
and ultimately we need Facebook it's
socially expected it's necessary and
it's a useful platform we're trapped so
the only thing to do is remember and to
help others learn if you don't control
the feed the feed is controlling you
John I'll see you on Tuesday
John our new media literacy series on
crash course with Jay smooth is so good
and fascinating and I want to tell
anyone who goes to watch it that it's
gonna change the way you see the world
around you forever it might be a little
less cut and dried but it's gonna be a
lot more accurate
you